BUT FIRST, A PARTY OF SNOBS.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
>> EVERY NOW AND THEN, A
POLITICIAN UNINTENTIONALLY
REVEALS WHO WE REALLY IS AND
WHAT HE REALLY BELIEVES.
>> I CAN TEACH ANYBODY, EVEN
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM, TO BE A
FARMER.
IT’S A PROCESS, YOU DIG A HOLE,
YOU PUT A SEAT ON, YOU PUT DIRT
ON TOP, UP COMES THE CORN.
YOU COULD LEARN THAT.
>> FIRST, HOW MUCH WOULD YOU PAY
TO SEE BLOOMBERG TRY TO DIG
DITCHES ALL DAY.
I WOULD PAY A LOT OF MONEY
PERSONALLY.
WHAT A SNOBBY ALETA’S THAT IS.
NOW FARMERS, AS YOU MIGHT
IMAGINE, WERE NOT AT ALL AMUSED.
THEY WERE LIGHTING UP TWITTER
WITH POLARIS.
I HAVE TO SAY, TO BE FAIR, THERE
IS CONTEXT.
CONTEXT TO EXPLAIN THESE
COMMENTS FROM BLOOMBERG.
NOW LOOK AT THIS HEADLINE IN THE
MILWAUKEE JOURNAL.
"BLOOMBERG APPEARS TO BE
INSULTING FARMERS, BUT THERE IS
MORE TO THE STORY" I HAVE A
QUESTION.
DO THEY EVER GET THE SAME CHANCE
TO EXPAND OUR CONTEXT?
FOR US, THERE IS NEVER MORE TO
THE STORY.
THEY JUST JUMP TO BOYCOTTS.
NONENEVERTHELESS, THIS IS WHAT
BLOOMBERG DID SAY.
>> WE HAVE 300 YEARS OF THE
INDUSTRIAL SOCIETY, YOU PUT THE
PIECE OF METAL COME YOU TURN THE
CRANK, DIRECTION OF THE ARROW,
AND YOU COULD HAVE A JOB.
THE ECONOMY IS FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT BECAUSE IT IS BUILT
AROUND REPLACING PEOPLE WITH
TECHNOLOGY.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LOT MORE GRAY
MATTER.
>> A LOT MORE GRAY MATTER?
OH, BOY.
SURE COME OF COURSE HE IS RIGHT
ABOUT TECHNOLOGY CHANGING THE
TYPE OF WORK WE DO.
THAT IS NOT EXACTLY A NOVEL
CONCEPT.
BUT CAN YOU IMAGINE IF
DONALD TRUMP SAID ANYTHING
APPROACHING THIS?
NOW THE MEDIA WERE RUSHING INTO
TO PROVIDE CONTEXT TO BLOOMBERG
WOULD PROCLAIM THAT TRUMP WAS
JUST INSULTING THE INTELLIGENCE
OF OTHERS.
ANY TIME PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TEAM
TRIES TO PROVIDE CONTEXT AFTER
ANYTHING THAT PEOPLE CONSIDER
CONTROVERSIAL LIKE
CHARLOTTESVILLE OR AFTER HIS
COMMENTS ABOUT THE WHERE THE
REFUGEES WE COME FROM, THEY ARE
JUST IGNORED.
BUT IS NOT JUST THE FARMERS THAT
BLOOMBERG HAS NO RESPECT FOR.
REMEMBER THAT TEXAS CHURCH
SHOOTING IN LATE DECEMBER?
WHEN AN ARMED CITIZEN SAVED
COUNTSCOUNTLESS LIVES BY SHOOTIN
KILLER DIED.
THIS WAS HIS TAKE AWAY.
>> IT IS THE JOB OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO HAVE GUNS AND
TO DECIDE WHEN TO SHOOT.
YOU JUST DO NOT WANT THE AVERAGE
CITIZEN CARRYING A GUN AND A
CROWDED PLACE.
>> YEAH, THEY ARE TOO STUPID TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES OR OTHERS FOR
THE USE OF A FIREARM THAT THEY
CARRY.
SAYS A MAN WHO IS AROUND THE
CLOCK AT SECURITY AND HAS HAD IT
FOR DECADES BY THE WAY.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT HE THINKS ABOUT
OVERWEIGHT AMERICANS.
YOU ARE ALL JUST TOO THICK TO BE
ABLE TO CONTROL YOUR OWN DRINK
SIZE AND YOUR INTAKE.
>> AT THE BOARD OF HEALTH ON THE
SERVING SIZE OF SUGARY DRINKS.
IN A RESTAURANT, 16 OUNCES IS
THE MAXIMUM THAT THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO SERVE.
IN ONE CUP.
WE ARE NOT TAKING AWAY ANYBODY’S
RIGHT TO DO THINGS, WE ARE
SIMPLY FORCING YOU TO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU HAVE TO MAKE THE
CONSCIOUS DECISION TO GO FROM
ONE CUP TO ANOTHER CUP.
>> OR SENIOR TO UNDERSTAND!
DON’T YOU THINK THAT THERE WOULD
PROBABLY BE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HE WOULD FORCE US TO UNDERSTAND?
IF YOU ARE PRESENT?
NOW HOW DID BLOOMBERG VIEW
PEOPLE OF FAITH?
WELL, HE SENT THAT MESSAGE A LOT
OF CLEAR WHEN HE WAS MAYOR OF
NEW YORK.
AT LEAST ON THE TENTH
ANNIVERSARY OF SEPTEMBER 11TH.
HE INCLUDED NOT A SINGLE FAITH
LEADER IN THE LIST OF SPEAKERS
AT THAT SERVICE.
WHEN HE WAS CALLED ON IT, THIS
IS WHAT MAYOR SNOB SAID.
>> THERE IS THIS SEPARATION OF
CHURCH AND STATE AND OUR
CONSTITUTION.
THE CONSTITUTION --
>> THAT DOESN’T MEAN THAT --
>> CAN YOU CLAIM TO BE WHAT
SQUARE DO YOU WANT?
YOUR RELIGION?
MY RELIGION?
HER RELIGION?
>> OKAY, PRIEST, RABBI,
MINISTER.
IT PRETTY MUCH COVERS IT.
HE IS DRIPPING WITH
CONDESCENSION.
AND REMEMBER, ON THE RESPECTIVE
FRONT, WOMEN.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE WHOLE
THING, WOMEN AREN’T REALLY
RESPECTED AS WOMEN WHO CAN HAVE
DIFFERENT VIEWS AND THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
BECAUSE IF THEY ARE PRO-LIFE,
THE ENTIRE PARTY HAS DRIVEN
PRO-LIFE WOMEN FROM THEIR RANKS.
THEY HAVE BASICALLY SAID AS MUCH
MUCH.
WOMEN WHO ARE PRO-LIFE ARE NOT
WELCOME.
AND BLOOMBERG IS GOING TO FIT IN
JUST FINE THERE.
HE IS PERSONALLY CONTRIBUTED
$14 MILLION TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD FROM 2014 TO 2017.
FIGURES PROBABLY UP BY NOW.
5.8 MILLION TO WOMEN’S VOTE.
THAT SINCE 2012.
AND HE HAD LINED THE 2018
NEW YORK CITY CONVENTION.
NOW REMEMBER, EMILY’S LIST
CLAIMS IT’S JUST FOR ELECTING
MORE WOMEN TO CONGRESS.
YOU LOOK AT THEIR LITTLE
WEBSITE, THAT’S WHAT THEY SAY
50,000 WOMEN.
BUT OF COURSE WHAT THEY REALLY
MEAN AS MORE PRO-ABORTION WOMEN
TO CONGRESS.
THE PARTY OF INCLUSION IS THE
OPPOSITE.
IT’S MORE RESTRICTIVE THAN IT
WAS 20 YEARS AGO IN THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
WHEN YOU REALLY THINK ABOUT
THIS, AND I THOUGHT OF IT A LOT
TODAY, THEIR BIG TENT COLLAPSED.
THAT TENT HAS BEEN REPLACED BY A
SAFE SPACE FOR LEFTIST VICTIMS
ONLY.
I THINK ABOUT SENATOR JOE
MANCHIN OF WEST VIRGINIA.
HE IS BASICALLY A WALKING
DEMOCRATIC STEGOSAURUS.
HE IS PRO-GUN, AND HE IS
PRO-LIFE.
NOT GOING TO BE MANY MORE OF HIM
AND HE SOON.
IMAGINE WHAT AOC PLUS THREE SAYS
ABOUT MANSION BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS?
GET OUT OF HERE.
NOW AT THE CORE OF ALL OF THIS
AID IS NOT JUST SNOBBERY, YACHTS
THAT, BUT IT’S A DEEP AND
UNWAVERING CONTEMPT FOR
TRADITIONAL AMERICAN IDEAL.
BECAUSE IN THIS ELITIST VIEW OF
SANCTIMONIOUS SNOBS, THE RIGHT
TO LIFE AND TO LIBERTY ARE
RESERVED ONLY FOR THOSE WHO
TRULY DESERVE TO HAVE THEM.
YOU HAVE TO THINK THE RIGHT WAY
TO HAVE THEM.
AND BLOOMBERG, HE IS KIND OF A
MINIATURE PONY AT TROTT HE A
WELL WORN DEMOCRAT PATH THERE.
FROM HILLARY’S DEPLORABLE’S TO
OBAMA’S BETTER CLEANERS, THE
LEFT LOVE TO TRASH THE COMMON
MAN WILL CLAIMING TO STAND UP
FOR HIM.
AND THEIR MEDIA ALLIES?
THEY ARE ALL TOO HAPPY TO ECHO
THE HATRED.
>> LET’S STOP CALLING TRUMP
VOTERS IDIOTS AND FOOLS AND CALL
THEM WHAT THEY ARE.
DRUG ADDICTS!
ANYBODY WHO ENABLES, ANYBODY WHO
VOTES FOR OR SUPPORTS A RACIST
IS A RACIST.
YOU ARE CULPABLE WHITE AMERICA,
I’M SORRY IF YOU VOTE FOR TRUMP.
YOU ARE THE BAD GUY.
>> YOU GOT THE IDEA.
IF YOU ARE WOKE, YOU ARE IN
LUCK.
IF NOT, YOU WILL BE DEMEANED OR
DRIVEN OUT OR JUST EXPUNGED.